[Music]
so I'm really gonna need you to get the
out
I have not held back at all I have been
myself and I have said what I wanted to
say when I wanted to say it what about
maybe one regret that you have about
what's happened so far I'm confident
with a group of men that I have right
now and so I don't have any regrets so
far but you know talk to me later what's
keeping you up at night like when you're
laying in bed in your room alone you're
just kind of thinking about all this
what's going through your mind I don't
like to hurt people's feelings
so even though I'm confident in the
decisions that I've made in sending
people home that's never easy how has
the process changed you or what has it
made you learn about yourself for me it
has taught me to be open you know I can
be not necessarily judge a book by its
cover but just kind of make my decisions
quickly and not allow someone the chance
to get to know me or for me to get to
know them and that's something that I
thought about when I started this whole
thing and so as I'm moving along through
this journey I'm just being open
you know to whatever these guys are
bringing me
[Music]
you